the article that came out saying the
fact that you guys lost 1.8 billion
dollars right and that happened by the
way did you guys have a margin call or
no did you get margin calls or no no
it's not okay so oh and I didn't and I
didn't toot our own horn but I will say
while we're at it we outperform Bitcoin
we're at 54 microstrategy stock has
outperformed every big Tech 95 in the
Nasdaq all the asset classes while we've
been
criticized for losing money on bitcoin
so why is it saying you guys lost one
point in a billion they're
when uh Bitcoin got to fifty thousand
dollars a coin
we sold a billion dollars worth of stock
yeah at 700 a share we converted the
equity into Bitcoin Bitcoin traded down
and so technically the Bitcoin that we
bought at that point is worth less today
and so you can say that's a non 20 about
a 32k or 39K something like that you
bought it at 39 000. if you bought
Bitcoin more than the current trading
price then you can say that you lost
money buying it but if you actually paid
for it with cash or Equity that was
valued proportionate then you've
actually created shareholder value we've
actually created Enterprise Value the
company's Enterprise Value is expanded
by a factor of five
our shareholders have made a made more
money than any other investment so
they're all fine
people are just cherry picking random
trading periods in order to make some
observation got it and in this story
here to the ethereum folks who would
love for me to ask you this question
there's no second best microstrategy
would be up 1.6 billion if it invested
in ethereum this was a month ago what
are your thoughts on this wonderful
article the problem is ethereum is a
security right I mean look I don't mean
to be mean about it but but it's pretty
evident vitalik is the CEO of ethereum
there is a 10-year road map with 160
blocks one of the little blocks in the
roadmap says elect secret leader another
block is give people the ability to
unstake their coin another block is set
the monetary policy like ethereum is an
incomplete uh crypto Network it's a work
in progress and so the problem
fundamentally is it's a security which
means to promote a security is
Securities fraud it's just it's that
simple right when you're promoting a
theorem you're promoting Joe Lubin and
vitalik's Company and it's their token
there was a pre-mine there's an Ico they
change the monetary policy and they
currently are holding 20 billion dollars
worth of their their investors assets
hostage
and we don't know when the money will be
released so here's the issue at some
point the SEC is going to deem them as
security if they are security it's
illegal to trade them on any exchange
you know in the U.S
really in the world right I mean and
unless someone creates a path to
register a digital security look I would
have nothing against ethereum if they
said look we're a company this is a
security we're going to register it okay
what's the board of directors who owns
it what's the rules give us all the risk
factors I mean a very simple question do
you know who's going to make the
decision to give the 20 billion dollars
of eth back
because there is no representation as to
when you'll be able to unstake eth it's
not clear who makes the decision
is it one what happens if that one
person disappears what if they decide to
never give you your wreath back
okay that that is a problem so as a
publicly traded company I'm going to
make a technical argument
publicly traded companies can't hold
more than 40 percent of their balance
sheet in a security like if it was Apple
stock and it had a hundred thousand
pages of disclosures I still couldn't
hold more than 40 percent of my balance
sheet in it because uh you know an
operating company can't hold any more
Securities without becoming SEC 40
reporting company it's a totally uh
different thing
so technically we couldn't buy
Securities if we wanted to
and uh and otherwise
look bitcoin's protocol has been pretty
much set in stone with a series of only
soft forks for 13 and a half 14 years
ethereum changes every six months those
you know and so it's a different thing
you know as for back testing it I mean I
I could go back and say what if I had
bought such and such yo-yo coin token
too but but as I've said the 22 000
tokens nearly all of them are
unregistered Securities which means
they're trading illegally unethically on
on illegal exchanges what could go wrong
like I I wouldn't put a penny
into any of those tokens if you said you
know My Cousin Vinnie's you know got
yo-yo dine and do you want to buy some
of the penny stock and just trust me
it's like no I mean it's no different
than boiler room right or you know the
Wolf of Wall Street
right the ethereum people have a they
have an aggressive technical ambition
But ultimately it's not a complete
project they've got a 10-year road map
when it's complete
five years after that you'll know if it
breaks or doesn't break and at some
point there's the question of you know
is it decentralized or not it's pretty
obviously not decentralized when you're
waiting for the supreme leader to give
you the plan so what all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valutamin it says future
looks right here future looks bright
here we got them in white we got them in
Black we got them in red our black on
black sold out these are about to sell
out if you haven't ordered one yet we
had a person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people wore it in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future look spread
toward your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]